الدراما اللي صايره في تويتر واللي بطلها
ال ماسك خلاص تحولت رسميه اللي نشره اخبار
يوميا فاليكم مشاهدينا نشرات اخبار مصر
اليوميه واللي بطلها اليوم مع ال مسك
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب فل
جالسين على تويتر اكيد شايفين اسم ترامب
منور الهاشتاجات ترند دونالد ترامب اللي
ما وقفت الناس من يوم ما فكر ماسك انه
يشتري تويتر ما وقفت تسال هترجع ترامب ولا
لا اليوم ورسميا ومن البوابه العريضه حساب
ترامب عاد الى تويتر والجماهير وقالت
كلمتها
اللي عملوا رئيس تويتر الجديد انه تطلع
رايي متابعي وقال لهم نرجع ترامب او لا
اكثر من 15 مليون صورته والنتيجه كانت
لصالح عوده ترامب بنسبه 52% و 48%
عرضوا الموضوع يعني انتم متخيلين ايش يعني
15 مليون جالسين بيشاركوا في استفتاء على
تويتر وعلى فكره من بين المصوتين سياسيين
ومشاهير طبعا وكان من بين ال 15 مليون
اللي صوتوا لهذه النتيجه رئيس الوزراء
الهنغاري فيكتور ارومان اللي نشر تغريده
شارك فيها الاستفتاء وقال خمن او خمن وكيف
ادليت بالصوتي تخمير الناس كان انه صوت
نعم كونوا له تصريحات سابقه داعمه ومادحه
في ترامب عموما بعد هذه النتائج
ماسك اعلن في تغريده انه ربطها بتغريده
الاستفتاء وقال الجماهير قالت كلمتها خلاص
ترامب
هنا عاد نيجي للنقطه الاهم ترامب اللي
تويتر كان في يوم من الايام منصه المفضله
ايش رايه في اللي بيصير ترامب عبر منصه
وتروس سوشل حط بوست للناس في لينك استفتاء
ماسك على تويتر وقال لي متابعوه او
لمتابعينه انه صوته بايجابيه لكن لا
تقلقوا ما هنروح مكان مختلف
كلام من فهم منه انه يعني مو ناوي يرجع
تويتر بس يعني ما في شيء واضح ورغم هذا
الشيء الحساب على طول حساب دونالد ترامب
في تويتر وفي اقل من 24 ساعه وهتى هذه
اللحظه الحساب مجمع 83 مليون متابع طبعا
احنا مشاهدينا بنقول لكم 83 مليون متابع
ترى هو قبل ساعه يعني قبل ما ندخل الهواء
كانت 72 مليون متابع شايفين يعني انتم همم
معدل الزياده كيف على العموم عيد واكرر
حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا مشاهدينا لان العداد
الحسابه
قبل الحظر من سنتين الحساب كان عليه 88
مليون متابع وكسور فهو يحطم هذا الرقم الى
جنب اخباركم
ناسيه تشتغل بجهد او جهزوا نفسكم انكم
تنطردوا بلومبرج بتقول انه ماسك بيجهز
دفعه جديده تنطرد يوم الاثنين وهذه المره
المستهدفين هيكونوا من اقسام المبيعات
والشركات وطبعا ما ننسى انه اصلا اللي
بيعملوا ماسك هذا خل الموظفين كثار
يختاروا هم انه يمشوا من نفسهم ومن كم يوم
كان في موجه استقاله جماعيه بين مهندسين
في الشركه اخبار طرد الالاف من موظفين
تويتر والاستقالات الجماعيه بين الموظفين
كان سبب في اطلاق هاشتاج تصدر التراند
عربيا اسمه اللي يسكر تويتر الاعتبار انه
يعني الموظفين كل ما لم بيقول له محب احد
يشغل المنصه خلاص
المغردين في اقتراح اشياء انه يلحق الواحد
يعملها قبل اللي يسكر
فنان فعليا في الكومنتات على تقفيله تويتر
لكن انا شخصيا كان عندي التعليق مفضل
خليني اشوفك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الا تراجع قلبك قبل ما يجري يوم السبت
وحياتي عندك لو كان ليا عنده قلبك
[موسيقى]
خذني معك خذ
ني ودار خدني
معاك
[موسيقى]
الاشواق
يوم